Can you hear me?
Oh,
you can hear me.
okay.
Well that's good.
Let me turn off.
Turn on music.
All Right,
nice.
Cool.
What I was trying to do
is
instead of using the laptop
video source was trying to hook up my dslr camera
is a canon add.
Yeah.
And I have that one of those Yeti mic hooked up.
Cool.
So I know you guys have probably seen it.
There's a whole lot of people that post,
you know,
Jordan Peterson stuff.
Um,
the only reason I stopped is because in September,
um,
I think it was mid September,
I received a message from youtube saying that my channel was going to be
demonetized a produce allocation.
There were other channels that got demonetized to like voltaire.
Um,
I'm drawing a blank,
but there were a few of the channels that would cut clips.
Uh,
I was kind of surprised that it happened.
Um,
but,
you know,
that's what happens.
Um,
so I'm not really sure what to do now.
I didn't stop.
I didn't stop posting Jordan's content because anything with the cabinet thing
seat,
the most amazing thing to me because I've listened to,
not all of his university lectures,
but all the Bible lectures,
probably each one at least two or three times,
not because I want to listen to it,
to her.
Oh yeah.
I liked,
I liked listening to them,
but the whole thing was,
the idea was I was editing,
so I was listening to segments over and over.
And as soon as I read the cabin,
I think I thought to myself,
Oh yeah,
I know what he's,
what he's getting at.
He's,
even though he didn't explain it to later,
I,
I instantly knew probably be because,
you know,
if all the stuff he says on youtube is any indication of his personality,
which you would imagine it would be.
Um,
the idea was that,
uh,
maybe we should,
maybe Kevin,
how should back off and let there be peace rather than
rather than,
uh,
so much turmoil.
I mean,
I didn't,
I don't really care.
I consider most of what's in what you see on the mainstream news to be.
Uh,
basically the,
the pr arm for the state,
that's what I consider politics basically the public relations arm for the
state.
Okay.
So it doesn't matter.
Kevin gets elected Kevin and doesn't get elected.
It doesn't matter.
You know,
Kevin was definitely a status as much,
as much as he could be one,
but.
And then,
um,
but there is one thing that I,
that I came across recently and that was a Peterson's.
I'm thinking,
I'm thinking how to thank you.
You need help here.
I don't know what that means,
what kind of help do I need?
But,
but um,
oh,
but the odd thing that,
that Peterson had tweeted out was the whole Holocaust denier being synonymous
with climate change.
Denial is that,
I don't know if I'm getting it right.
You guys remember that tweet.
I don't fall,
uh,
Jordan Peterson's twitter that often.
Um,
but I've tried to get in contact with a publicist to ask for permission to.
We broadcast this stuff so I could forward an email to youtube and hopefully get
re monetized.
I don't know that that's going to happen,
but.
So yeah.
Mm,
mm
mm.
Yeah.
I don't have anything with Peterson today.
Penguins are upside down.
Yeah.
Well
that's fine with me.
Yeah,
it should be clear.
Is it looking like it's pretty clear.
I think that if I had a.
How about I pay pal you?
Yeah.
I don't think I can turn on super chat because I'm no longer a part of the
youtube part or program.
Um,
well that's good.
I think the video would probably be even clear if I had a,
uh,
a lens with a lower stop.
You can start posting about your own ideas since he might've taken some
influence from Latinos.
Peterson lectures.
Well,
funny enough.
Um,
no,
I've,
I've thought quite a bit more.
I'm kind of looking at streaming options here.
Do
you have a son?
I go into the CEO Volusia Pako
was Spanish and I don't know that song.
What's the topic?
Or May I suggest one?
Yes.
Your own ideas.
Give us some.
Well,
uh,
I don't think that I'm,
well I'm still kind of trying to learn a little bit more about history.
Like for instance,
uh,
I started watching,
Chris hedges on Youtube who was a war correspondent,
a journalist,
and he's written quite a few books.
One of the more interesting books is a book of his called a war force that gives
us meaning
and,
and
sorry,
I get sidetracked.
I start to want to read the chat.
And uh,
Chris Hedges book is basically about,
um,
I haven't,
I haven't read it.
Uh,
I've,
I've got hedge,
his newest book America,
the fell,
fell,
fell where the farewell tour,
sorry,
it's a bit dyslexic but not his,
uh,
as far as I know his first book,
a force to gives us meaning,
but it's about basically,
you know,
that soldiers,
um,
people in combat,
you don't have a lot to relate to a,
especially when they start,
when they make,
when they make contact.
So,
you know,
they develop this,
I dunno,
it,
it just gives soldiers meaning combat gives soldiers meaning and when they come
home it becomes a whole lot more difficult to assimilate to something that
doesn't recognize combat at all.
Um,
so,
but I was,
someone asked me,
you know,
some of your own ideas.
Well,
I've recently found out that,
uh,
some of the
people that brought us,
if you're an employee in the United States
in the early,
early 20th century,
the early 20th century
workers had a lot to be
upset about.
Their living conditions were bad.
They worked a tremendous amount of hours for little pay for as far as I know,
next to no ability to advance at all in society.
That's the majority,
not just a generalization,
so no workers started to strike and a lot of,
not a lot of,
but an organization,
the industrial workers of the world,
which was a socialist organization which had both socialists and communists in
it,
um,
advocated on behalf of American workers to strike.
And from what I've read,
the,
uh,
the beginning of the strikes,
the beginning of the strikes were a
peaceful,
nonviolent,
and the state,
not just the state,
sorry,
not the state that first.
But first corporations were,
you know,
became very apprehensive to the idea of strike from what I've read.
And so they started to hire a militias in local organizations to try and police
and intimidate,
and I use violence against the peaceful protests to the point where when the
protests became so out of hand,
the companies would,
would petition the state,
the state would petition the federal government,
and then they would bring in the military,
um,
to put down strikes.
And,
you know,
I don't know,
I'm not that,
uh,
I don't know that much about history,
but,
you know,
I try and look at parallels that are happening.
And,
you know,
one thing that I saw you,
uh,
um,
one thing that I saw was around the same time,
the,
uh,
revolutions in Russia we're going on.
So maybe the,
maybe the state
basic to understanding history,
understanding human nature,
um,
but the,
so maybe the state thought that what was happening in eastern Europe was going
to happen in the United States.
Um,
so I could see why there would,
there there were legitimate.
Although I don't think that that's really,
that's the truth.
That's just one possibility.
Um,
so I find it very interesting that socialists and communists are the ones that
advocate it and eventually got to giving,
um,
the better living standard of the
American employee.
Um,
you know,
if you're self employed,
you don't follow the same guidelines.
I'm lucky now because I'm self employed.
I'm a cabinet installer,
matures carpenter,
but much better and finished carpentry then rough carpentry.
Um,
but I'm not an employee so,
you know,
I'm,
I'm lucky a lot of ways and you know,
people I've left comments and comment sections.
This guy is boring.
Nice,
low key.
Well I'm,
I forgot I was going to say,
oh,
people have said to me,
well,
what if I don't want to work?
So the,
all those socialist movements,
the communist movements,
the strikes basically gave you the American worker like an eight hour working
day,
weekends,
a,
a better standard of living.
And you know,
where that contrasts with Peterson's idea that you know,
you shouldn't,
it's not a good idea to,
to place a group above you,
you know,
if I'm saying it correctly,
will,
the idea is that they're not,
you know,
these people are not only advocating for everyone for a better living standard
for everybody else,
but also for themselves.
So a,
and people have tried to rebut the idea of,
you know,
what if I don't want to work eight hours,
well,
what if I want to work 12 hours or 14 hours?
Well,
okay,
but what if you weren't making even minimum wage?
What if you were making
a dollar,
$2 to $3 an hour?
Um,
you know,
working a 16 hour days for $3 an hour would be a,
would be really rough.
And something that I've recently learned about,
uh,
in the libertarian camp was a little big on me.
So this was actually advocating for workers across the world so that trade could
flow freely.
That worker is,
like I said,
across the world would be paid the same,
so the migrant workers would be paid well.
So what that would do was basically reduced the American living standard and
European living standard down to that,
of the migrants,
which at that time I think we're Chinese and black workers.
Um,
so a lot of people don't know that about me,
sis.
Uh,
I mean,
uh,
it just doesn't sound like a very good idea that,
that means that you and probably all 33 people watching right now wouldn't ever
have been able to get out of
what would be far below poverty in the,
in the West now.
Um,
and,
you know,
so
it's just weird that that's kind of stamped,
that's kind of stamped out of history in a lot of people don't know that.
I certainly did.
No,
that I'm,
I don't know,
I'm definitely
don't have any type of ideology,
I believe that will fix anything.
I personally like a Karl Popper's idea of open society.
I don't even know that much about Karl Popper,
but the,
I,
the concept of open society is that in order to,
uh,
it's not George Soros Open society though he may have grabbed ideas from it for
his organization,
Karl Popper philosophers idea of an open society was that,
that everything is in flux and ideas are dynamic and times change and that you
constantly have to figure out what's going to work and if that means
experimenting with,
with different
social ideas or
it's just the idea that there's never any one set of ideas.
Nothing's ever final.
Everything has to be under constant scrutiny,
which,
you know,
if you extrapolate that out to the individual,
if you are constantly policing,
policing is a good word.
But being mindful of yourself,
uh,
then
and taking action to do what's best for you,
then you know,
you'll probably
come out.
Well,
I don't think that the future is going to be.
I don't think that Americans,
especially in the future,
are going to survive in the exact same system that they have now.
Um,
basically the whole idea of profit being the bottom line.
I mean,
you hear people
every once in awhile I'll,
I'll see something on Fox News and
uh,
and there was a segment,
I think it was on Fox business news and this guy was saying,
well,
how do you know what,
what arguments do you use against people who claim that socialism the answer?
And he said,
well,
just look at the Internet.
Well,
you know,
that's another thing that you,
you have to know something about and you know,
whereas,
you know,
Ebay was the perfect example of a free market to begin with.
I don't know that it's still like that.
Free markets existed on the Internet,
but the Internet itself is the product of a socialist institution,
a centralized institution.
The United States military and the Department of Defense,
Advanced Research,
uh,
you know,
it was arpanet before it became the Internet.
Um,
so no socialism gave you the Internet,
uh,
you know,
tax dollars gave you,
what we enjoy today.
Um,
and something that I've,
I don't know that much about.
But,
uh,
as far as I know,
Marxism is a critique,
you know,
it's like saying that,
I guess I'm trying to say that
Marxism didn't kill
however many people in,
uh,
in Europe.
Well,
you know,
Stalin was in eastern Europe.
Stalin was basically a thug.
He was a lot like the United States organized criminals,
you know,
he was just a,
he was basically just a gangster who rose to the head of the state.
But Marxism is a critique of,
uh,
financial institutions or I get.
Sorry,
economics.
Marxism is,
is a critique of economics.
I don't know that much about Marxism,
but like I said,
the idea would be that Marxism didn't kill 'em.
However many people that would be like saying that Algebra killed the people in
Nagasaki and Hiroshima,
you know,
it's not,
you can't make that distinction,
you know,
as much as Peterson says that Marxism is a,
it's a philosophy of resentment.
That may be true,
you know,
I don't know that much about marks.
Um,
one thing that I've heard from people who have read mark's more that's
interesting is that mark spoke out against a financial speculation.
Um,
much of what gave you much of what gives a Western societies the bubbles that
are created,
the housing bubble,
the,
uh,
securities bubble,
the bubble that we have now that's,
that's bursting.
I'm not only is it bad for,
well,
I don't know why it would be bad for people on the way up,
but on the way down when the bubble bursts,
you have the,
uh,
finance financial institutions,
the banks that just go ahead and buy up all the assets of the people that can no
longer afford things.
Um,
so,
you know,
it,
it would seem that mark's had some good ideas though.
His character,
the character of his person wasn't
an marble,
but,
you know,
maybe some of his ideas,
maybe some ideas of Marxism are worth noting.
Um,
you know,
obviously private property seems like a pretty good thing to me.
Um,
but like I said,
I'm much more towards Karl Popper's idea of an open society.
So it shouldn't just be,
uh,
you know,
straight capitalism or straight socialism,
it should be basically,
there should be little experiments in the economy.
A company's,
you know,
for instance,
in,
as far as I know in Germany for corporations that have over a thousand for
corporations that have over a thousand or so people
for corporations and what the hell is up in this chat for corporations that have
more than a thousand or so people.
I'm the executives are actually voted on by the workers.
I don't know if that's true.
I've heard that a,
if that is true,
you know,
that's
um,
I mean these are just little things that,
you know,
why isn't,
why isn't anything?
Why doesn't anything ever change?
Well,
of course,
you know,
there's always unintended consequences and you go ahead and you solve one
problem and you create a whole bunch of others,
which is true.
Um,
but there's no,
it doesn't seem like there's enough innovation and economics.
I mean,
not that I know that much,
but it seems like we're reaching a pretty bad
time now.
And there's other one point of contention they have with Peterson,
you know,
where is he says,
people in the West
are the,
the people who are the poorest are still among the one percent of the world.
Well,
you know,
I kinda like to
though,
I don't know,
always know if it's appropriate.
Basically go from micro to macro and by that I mean that maybe we shouldn't
judge the western countries shouldn't judge themselves based on,
uh,
the other countries of the world.
We shouldn't judge ourselves based on poor countries,
but by where we were at,
where we are at,
I think that if we,
we did that,
you know,
maybe we would,
uh,
move forward.
I don't know what the hell that means.
I mean if I was,
you know,
an executive,
a making a whole lot of money,
it would basically just be the status quo for me.
So I can understand why things don't change or they change very slowly.
I'm just kinda rambling.
What are your thoughts on the reason behind almost everyone in the photo is her.
I don't know anything about that.
You guys have any questions?
I don't know if I can answer anything.
No.
So yeah,
I dunno.
Ideas I have are still being formulated,
but
I don't think it's ever a good idea to just write off
right off all that's something.
I mean financial speculation,
gambling,
financial,
gambling use.
It used to be illegal and now it's not,
um,
you know,
the idea that speculation is a good thing because,
speculation can be a good thing because then it allows banks to lend more money
so an economy can be more productive.
I've read that in some article that was probably,
uh,
some bank funded article or somebody that paying
for those views to be me put out,
I don't know.
But you know,
Karl Popper's open society,
the philosopher Karl Popper and the idea of open society now.
That's not as far as I know,
that's not open borders.
That's not,
you know,
what all migrants in that's
more of a way I think to organize,
organize a state.
Mm.
I'm not really too concerned with
the Jews so much.
Don't really understand why.
That's why is that such a big thing in the
hmm?
Mm,
mm,
mm.
As little Sunday night rather than a few days ago.
Just simple stupid shit.
Mm MM.
Wow.
There was a comment that was held for review.
It's interesting.
I don't understand why that's.
I don't pay a whole lot of attention to,
to a
Jewish conspiracy theories.
Mm.
I really don't make too much sense to me.
Mm,
mm,
mm.
The idea that
Jews are behind
most of the ills of the world,
I think most of the ills of a world can be chalked up to people,
not a
first a degradation in the family.
That's the primary reason in the West for the breakdown of everything.
The breakdown.
I don't even know what that means.
You know,
the thing is if people wanted to get up and start making noise like is being
done in France,
then
things would change.
You know,
Frank Douglas has a famous quote that power concedes nothing unless people
demand of it,
and that's the truth.
If people don't get out in the streets,
then nothing happens.
Mm
minimalism
or anything?
Mm.
Mm,
mm.
I don't know that much about
way of life.
What do you mean
minimalism?
Like doing the least amount of what's required to get by in life?
Working part time.
What do you mean?
Mm.
I don't quite understand what you mean by it's Jordan Peterson's guitar son.
This isn't his son,
man.
MMM.
This isn't a Julian.
This isn't Julian.
This is some guy who's only met Peterson once
and that was only at one of his lectures.
Basically it was all the money that I made up youtube.
I felt kind of obligated to give back a little bit.
How dare you resent your,
uh,
minimalistic way of life living on minimal things.
Anti-Capitalism,
living in a van,
having one plate,
one spoon,
and barely any necessity
living in a van.
I don't
know
that van would have to be fairly nice size having one plate.
Yeah.
I'm cool with having one plate and one set of utensils until you get people that
come over and then what the hell do you do then?
You know,
now if it's a girl you can eat off the same plate,
but it's a bunch of people you don't know.
Not Everybody's going to want to eat off that one plate and use the same floor
work.
Living in a van.
There's a whole lot of people who live in vans now.
It's kind of a big thing
living in an rv.
He's living in vans.
I guess in San Francisco.
A lot of people have to live in their vehicles because they can't afford
it.
Can't afford the real estate prices,
whether it be renting or owning
adjunct professors have to live in vans.
People involved in Silicon Valley and live in vans.
That kind of sucks.
Hm,
okay.
Mm.
I think that if a,
I wanted to travel,
maybe living in a van would be a cool thing,
but
I'm not interested that interested in traveling around the United States right
now.
Minimal things anti-capitalism.
Well,
I got another little rant for you.
You know,
trump's whole thing with food chain and blaming China
four.
Well,
I don't know exactly what he's blaming China for,
but you know,
United States companies moved to China and though Chinese work in them,
there's still a lot of American corporations that
basically,
or making things
and the reason that a lot of the things that are made cheaply is because the
bids are so low,
you know,
you,
you can only do,
you can only make so much of something.
You can only keep the quality of something so high when you're being paid so
much.
So.
No,
that's,
uh,
that's what I've heard.
But they probably do steel.
I mean,
China is not good.
That's not a good place in that they steal a lot of the,
uh,
a lot of,
technology when they can.
But I've kind of find it interesting that people would think that a state would
not mean a state is ruthless.
You know what I mean?
Our federal government is ruthless.
Um,
you know,
when you're in the Geo political game,
I don't think that there are any rules.
I think it's basically what you can get away with.
Um,
and that's it.
No.
When there's egg on your face when you take a step back,
but it's
uh,
it's a different
set of arrangements.
Um,
[inaudible] you have any questions?
Any other questions?
One of these lights?
I don't know.
It's kind of bright.
Yeah.
Haven't noticed.
There's a lot of people that
really
got upset with Jordan.
Peterson of the Kevin thing,
whatever.
I'm not hanging on some guys.
Every words on twitter.
Oh God.
It's so funny.
So many different camps on the Internet,
on Youtube.
It doesn't resemble the world that much.
Real world.
I don't know that many original songs,
so I can't play you.
I used to,
I used to do on guitar was learning other people's songs,
but probably for five,
six years I.
where is all this going,
Bruh?
Division in this country is getting pretty out of hand.
Is Social media to blame?
Well,
I don't know.
I don't know anything,
but
where is all this going?
Probably
probably just more division.
I couldn't see it going.
I couldn't really see it going anywhere else besides that right now is social
media to blame?
Well,
I believe that with Youtube and all specifically youtube,
you have the comments section,
you have a video,
you watch something,
you know,
you got an idea or something,
so you want to jot it down on the,
uh,
um,
in the comments section and then you think that you're,
you know,
you're responding to somebody.
I think I've heard Sam Harris say something about this.
It might've been somebody else and you think that you're,
you're
entering into a conversation with somebody,
you know what I mean?
Like there's,
this dialogue is being opened up and there's not,
you know,
it's basically,
oh,
I think it was Shapiro at some point you said something about that.
The idea is,
is that somebody posts a comment and you post a comment and somebody has already
moved on,
you know,
their,
uh,
the uh,
the context isn't
there anymore,
I don't know,
but social media to blame,
you know,
people face to face and people in the comments section or two entirely different
things
and people get really upset and
about her
in comment sections.
That probably wouldn't happen
then I'm
probably wouldn't happen in real life in reality.
Yeah,
I don't know where it's gone.
Like I said,
more division.
Um,
put the guitar down.
When you speak,
he's use your hands to emphasize points.
You'll be a much stronger speaker.
Oh,
I didn't know this was a toastmasters
wasn't aware.
God,
look at me.
I'm in the corner of a room.
I used to have a little studio.
You got anything else?
Mm,
mm,
mm.
And that just go on,
loop around,
around.
And then finally I came up with
mm,
mm.
Bit Darker.
Mm mm,
mm,
mm.
Yeah.
They are looking kind of batty.
They are birds.
Weight bats are birds.
Are they?
This is El Dragon.
I asked because I am the former.
How do I turn off having to review comments.
I don't want to have to review people's comments.
I asked because I am the former.
You,
the vitriol between the groups left and right.
Black white is as bad or even worse than than the prewar Yugoslavia.
Oh,
I don't know much
about Eastern Europe.
I mean,
the most I know about you could Slavia is what I've heard from Chris Hedges.
Vision is fishing.
Well,
I don't know that its vision
using union is fusion.
Mm mm,
mm.
Mm.
Yeah.
It's kind of Nice being able to
take
scientific concepts and apply them to
other areas in life.
Hmm.
Character of Jesus Christ is fishing.
I don't know anything about that.
What do you think?
Jesus Christ came to divide.
Oh,
is that what that is about?
The Salvation Army band.
I don't know if somebody was blasting some music.
I heard a uh.
Oh,
you know,
you're right.
That's what it is.
It's the,
uh,
the subdivision that I live in,
the homeowner's association is really involved,
so there's a,
a it bring the firetrucks around.
I'll have music playing
this Christmas will be a little bit more difficult.
Well this whole past few months have been difficult because my father died in
July,
has been tough.
Mm MM.
Yeah.
I don't really
have that much more to,
and they contribute and lost the dashboard.
How did he pass?
Um,
well,
didn't have cancer.
The cancers would kill them.
I think an infection in his money
and infection,
I believe killed him.
Yeah.
He had a soft Gel,
cancer in 2004.
He was involved in an auto accident,
which he,
it was a not,
he wasn't at fault.
Basically.
He was at a red light and a guy driving a vehicle
dropped his phone when I had a to go grab his phone and instead of hitting the
brake pedal the gas pedal and accelerated into my dad sitting at a red light.
And of course you know,
is a domino effect.
My Dad went ahead and hit another car,
so it was a bad accident for him.
And a few other people in my dad had some
extremely bad headaches.
So he would take it,
be popping tylenol three or four a day and a
sure enough,
um,
once his cancer was diagnosed and we were surprised that it,
that it wasn't as far as we could tell primarily in his lungs.
That is a soften that,
so there's a correlation that's been found,
a,
there's medical articles that found a correlation between asset ace and
medicine,
which is something that allows the medication to be absorbed quicker.
I believe as a metaphor,
a metaphor.
It's like tylenol and asymmetric when,
like when you get a hydrocodone,
hydrocodone for pain reliever,
like when you have your wisdom tooth pulled out,
which I just had recently,
you probably can't see it on the screen,
but um,
I believe that allows your body to absorb the pain reliever,
the hydrocodone,
the opioid more effectively.
Um,
but uh,
as a matter of fin is also correlated
with a,
like an
longterm use is correlated with esophageal cancer.
So
for awhile I thought that's what Gildan tylenol and not cigarettes.
He smoked cigarettes quite a bit,
but I don't think it was cigarettes,
you know,
some people have the genes for it and some people don't and I don't think the
cigarettes when we've got them.
Um,
so
yeah,
open up a bit about yourself.
Well,
my mind's gone blank.
I don't know.
What do you want to know?
I didn't know that.
It's made from the poison
from apricots,
like what does it synthesized from the Afrikaans or something?
I don't know.
Cancer is a rebellion within the body.
Yeah.
Well I'm,
I'm upset.
I'm the ad revenue that I was getting from Peterson's reposting things pretty
substantial for awhile
and you know,
Youtube sent me a letter saying,
sent me a letter saying that I need permission.
I went ahead and looked for an email and of course I think it's Peterson's
publicist.
The handle is emails,
but I was hoping to maybe get and eat,
uh,
an email from him or somebody
so that I could go ahead and forward that to youtube and maybe get my channelry
monetized.
I
mean like,
um,
yeah.
So that may not happen
and
if it doesn't then I should find something else to do with this.
With this channel.
Your commentary on Peterson is permissible.
Yeah.
But is it monetizeable?
You know what I mean?
I didn't start doing the clip thing for the money,
but when the money started rolling it was kind of Nice and I thought,
oh,
this is decent,
this is decent.
And they're just like hockey sticked
and then,
and then when I,
the the video that I uploaded that get the most views and the shortest amount of
time was an accident because I was clipping like five minute,
five minute long clips.
No.
And
I accidentally put a posted because I had ripped the video and then I went ahead
and clicked it like I had like three clips done.
And then I excellent closed one of the folders.
So I went pack open the folder,
drag it over to the,
to the uh,
upload thing and I'm uploaded it and I'm thinking I'm looking at it thinking
what the hell?
And it took 15 minutes to upload and it was getting stock interview right after
the cat,
Kathy Newman.
And I'm sitting here like,
what the hell?
Why did this video take so long?
Why is it taking so long to upload?
And of course I'm doing something else,
you know,
I have a desktop computer.
I was doing something talking to my friends and I go back and look at my.
And I go back and I'm,
what the hell is taken so long?
And sure enough,
I have uploaded the full,
the full video and out of sheer laziness,
I just thought to myself,
I'm not even gonna worry about it.
I'm just gonna Hey Joe,
I'm just going to let it hang out and whatever.
I'll just get up Rhonda,
load another video and then sure enough,
20 minutes go by and you know,
I would check,
uh,
I would check the analytics and I'm looking at it and you know,
I'm
pretty good about
what statistics I should be following on.
I'm not good with statistics,
but average is I should be following.
And it was like,
man,
this is like way,
way beyond what I thought and then then I just kinda got greedy at that point.
I just started just what the hell.
And just start like taking until you hand gets slapped.
Well,
I mean,
you know,
it's just like,
you wonder why things don't change in the states,
you know,
why you have a for profit healthcare system that the insurance companies own
everything and you know,
everyone's,
everyone wants to make it out.
Like,
oh,
can't change.
And it's for the better.
And
that's bullshit.
The only reason it doesn't change,
just because you don't see people out in the street,
like in France,
I mean it's so bad in the states that,
that doctors make mistakes and people die and people aren't accountable.
And in Europe there
they're uh,
in France,
they're a,
there a,
what do you call it,
a,
they're protesting over diesel tax and people are dying in the states because of
malpractice because they're not valuable enough because they can't,
they don't have as much money,
you know,
their insurance company is not the company that is not the type of insurance
that your doctor will take.
Lucky for me at the few things that I've had recently,
I've just been able to pay with cash,
but you know,
that's not the case with a,
with a lot of people.
Hey Adam.
But yeah,
things won't change in the states until people
get up.
Which now,
I don't know.
The states seemed like the most isolated nation on planet earth.
Cash is king.
Who is the Queen?
I don't know.
How old are you?
Really old?
Let me guess.
Credit.
Yeah,
I've,
I've heard that the
average person has $60,000 in credit card debt.
That's unreal.
I just use my,
uh,
I just use my credit card to build credit,
you know what I mean?
Keeping the account open for six months to a year.
Close it open.
Another one.
We're ruled by Queen.
I'm doing good.
I only have 59,000.
Yes,
I'm,
I'm 31.
We are ruled by Queen.
Oh,
that means.
Yeah,
there's not a whole lot.
I never enter into these with really anything to
say.
Partly because I'm
lazy.
I mean this,
this entire thing was a test to see if my dslr would
with handled the
would handle
will be functional.
It is.
I think next time we'll change the lenses so I get a bit of f stop so I don't
have to use this.
I don't have to use this light.
I turned it down.
Delays so much on the computer that I can immediately tell.
What
did we pass your test?
Yeah.
Oh,
Adam,
if you're still here.
Um,
funny enough.
Before you posted that Richard Wolf,
that video on Richard Wolff,
I had actually been watching,
um,
I had been watching things on like Russia,
TV,
Russia,
America,
that channel and along with Chris Hedges on contact,
I had seen Richard Wolf and not,
I don't really know so much about the.
Oh,
hold on.
The camera died.
Let me replace the battery.
Well,
we got.
No,
no,
that's the battery's dead.
No.
Yeah.
Okay.
Sounds like he's wrestling liberals.
Uh,
and this is a,
this is kind of difficult.
Oh Damn.
Delay is so bad on the computer that I can't.
Oh,
nice.
Should,
should be able to see me now.
Well,
you know,
I don't really like the whole idea of hating liberals.
You know,
the whole idea was that
there again,
the same people that bought the better living standards of the American employee
were socialists and communists,
the industrial workers of the world marching in the early 20th century,
striking alongside workers as they could have a better living standard.
Those people were liberals and there again,
if they hadn't existed that,
you know,
the majority of us would,
uh.
Well,
I can understand your thing with abortion there,
Joe,
but the whole idea that if they hadn't existed that the American worker would be
paid probably as much as the Chinese worker,
if not less.
I mean,
you know,
the American living standard,
we owe unfold,
but unfortunately,
but we owe
to people who were self-described communists and socialists in a large,
in large part
had the strikes occurred without them,
I don't know,
but they were the,
uh,
the industrial workers of the world.
The wobblies were the ones that get the credit.
You don't learn that in school that much.
So I don't like the idea of really hating
liberals,
but
I guess I guess the whole thing is that,
you know,
it's,
it's a catchall term
in a lot of ways.
There's a lot of catch all terms,
like
neoliberalism is a catchall,
but I guess yeah,
I could see what you mean.
I mean,
I don't even consider kids out in the street and colleges,
liberals,
they're just,
they're just kids doing stupid shit.
Maybe they didn't get the anchor of their system when they were young,
you know?
I don't know.
So yeah,
I don't,
uh,
I don't really want to play any,
um,
any youtube videos because like playing on the screen because if I do that I
could get a copy struck,
you know what I mean?
Don't want that.
That's the one thing I'm happy about is that I only have to deal with copyright
strikes right now.
Jordan Peterson's maps.
A meeting.
That's not a good title.
Does the truth hang out?
That's a better.
Yeah.
I mean,
I don't have anybody on here to talk with,
so
my face has a box on it.
I'll fix that.
It's a leveling function.
Oh No,
I'm upside down.
Okay.
Um,
just like the penguins,
the penguins are.
Writes that up.
Yeah,
it's better now.
Yep.
And I am.
Hmm.
What's more enjoyable for the penguins?
So I don't know what to do.
Maybe I should bring the camera with me and film me installing a kitchen.
Maybe overlay it with some commentary.
I don't know how fitting it would be for this channel.
I have the idea of going back and actually taking every single one of the videos
that I've put out,
which is probably an 800 now
every single video and basically
cutting it up and putting commentary over every single one so I can.
Yeah,
that might not be such a bad idea.
That would
potentially qualify,
but then you know,
you,
you get 100,
you get 100 videos in,
maybe not 100.
Maybe you get 60 videos in and don't even know if you don't even know if you're
going to get monetized.
I mean that's the whole point of this now.
No,
I wouldn't let anybody fully it.
Most people do this
for the money.
No,
I certainly did.
Not to begin with,
but
the snacks,
I don't know.
Snacks and just peanuts,
peanuts,
almonds,
walnuts.
Hazelnuts.
Yeah,
there.
I guess.
No.
For years for me,
they were basically a staple and I put them in everything.
Soups.
Yeah.
The street.
Chris.
I had gotten that red dead redemption game and
played it and
about a ps four just to play that stupid game and the only reason I'm going to.
The only reason I've kept the PS four is to play final fantasy seven remake
comes out and then I'm going to ditch the playstation
because I don't.
I
don't play
console games that much.
Just got to prove that the earth is flat.
What's that?
Joe?
Joe Can prove to us that the earth is flat.
Have you seen the South Park?
Is Hamlet Red Dead Redemption?
Yeah.
I saw a clip of it and I thought it was hilarious.
Oh
God.
It is.
It's,
it's to a tee.
I mean,
I played that thing.
Okay,
so I'm self employed.
So
what the.
Oh Man.
Battery number two.
Debt gone.
Here we go.
Let's see.
We got to
run out of batteries here.
This may come to an early ending.
I'm going to go ahead and get one of those batteries.
You plug in
remote shooting.
Oh,
what you mean?
who's that box again?
Get a Webcam that plugs into your pc.
I've got a really nice dslr camera.
I plugged it into my pc.
I think I'd rather use the DSLR.
I just need to get the.
A,
the battery that plugs into an outlet.
You know what I mean,
know what I mean.
Can you guys
shit?
Can you see me?
Oh,
you're seeing that crap again.
Boy,
a boy.
Oh boy.
Let's see if we can fix this.
Yes,
he is going on here.
Um,
what the hell?
Huh?
There we go.
Oh Shit.
That looks terrible.
Going on there.
Okay.
Sorry guys.
Sorry about that.
Don't tip pizza delivery person to deliver out number of pizzas licensed.
They've already had their tip from your meal.
What about if you've got a,
a square cut pizza?
Like I'm from Chicago that you don't cut it in big slices.
Like you cut it in squares,
you know,
Kinda like how Chicago is.
The city is laid out,
you know what I mean?
In the real grid like fashion,
you're going to sit there and count all those pieces and see if you got an even
or odd number.
Yup,
Yup.
Yeah.
I don't really have anything.
Beer by slaughter beach dog.
I don't know how that is mad.
Maybe the dog.
Yep.
So it seems like every,
everything's coming to an end here
link way too
in a long time.
So is there a blink lady too?
It looks grainy.
Picture looks kind of grainy.
Like the ISO or the cameras?
No.
Yep.
So what do we got?
Anything else?
What else is going on?
Please
free to raise a great goodbye song.
Free Word is the most requested song.
I could play the one song that.
But last time on here.
Mm MM.
Type of the blackbird.
Well I guess since the 14th amendment.
The blackboard screen now?
Yeah.
Fair to say burden of color.
Yo.
Why won't Jordan Peterson say he believes in God?
I think he talks about them enough.
I mean come on.
Yeah,
he does these frigging biblical lectures.
I don't have to ask somebody.
Do you believe in God?
No.
I could care less.
What your beliefs are
it just get back to real talk.
Oh yeah,
yeah.
Oh I'm sorry.
Yeah.
Well,
uh,
I was seeing a Owen Owen Benjamin's livestream
and you know,
they bring on,
brings it up quite a bit.
The
thing with a.
Why would he answer a simple question?
I mean he tells you because he doesn't want to be reduced to a soundbite.
And the thing is,
in his lecture,
nobody's asking him questions and his two hour long lectures,
nobody's asking him questions if people continuously grinded him,
if everybody in a q and a period just got together and said,
look,
we're just gonna keep asking him the same question over and over,
you know,
you might get some more information out of him,
but
it's fine with me.
I don't expect a bunch of
new information to come out of him.
I mean,
what I found most interesting
was that he was putting biblical stories into perspective to the point where
a mechanic friend of mine,
who I had come out and do the struts,
the rear struts on my car,
you know,
he goes to ease really religious guy and we're sitting down and I was talking
about,
Oh,
you know,
I do this thing on youtube.
I cut clips.
He's like,
Oh yeah,
okay,
well,
you know,
what do you do?
And I said,
oh,
well there's this,
a clinical psychologist out of Toronto University professor.
He ran a private practice,
all this Yada,
Yada,
Yada.
I still talking about the,
a biblical lectures.
So I start,
uh,
so I started telling him about the,
I'm having trouble remembering it now.
I think
with Jacob,
you had the idea of
like a,
the idea of permanence and the plate placing,
placing something down and basically centering around that one thing.
Um,
I'm terrible at being able to explain things but not with John Height that would
be like circling,
you know,
the one thing being able to get around this one state of permanence,
state of permanence,
this object permanence,
you know,
it could probably be anything in eminent inanimate object or a person that's
probably what people do with clergy,
but,
you know,
there's a lot of benefits I think to,
uh,
to Jordan Peterson's lectures.
And um,
one thing that I've found interesting was Fox day mentioned that,
well,
you know,
if you listen to Jordan Peterson,
then you're probably already pretty messed up already and there's probably
something wrong with you.
Well,
I was listening to his,
uh,
to his lectures and they seemed pretty interesting,
you know,
he was putting a different perspective
on
stories and
I just don't think that's the case.
I mean,
I worked in a Woodshop,
I worked in a cabinet shop where I would put furniture together,
either I worked in tandem with people or I worked by myself and I mean this is a
high end accustomed wood shop,
you know,
doing $60,000 to a million dollar houses.
Um,
and I basically,
you know,
in the beginning of the day,
you just get a clipboard,
fair out what you're going to do and you start doing it.
So I would put on headphones and just listen.
And I found Peterson and I was like,
yeah,
hell yeah,
I'll listen to some of these.
And,
you know,
he uh,
through him I,
you know,
I knew about but didn't know the extent to which it would be interesting,
the Gulag archipelago.
So I listened to probably five or six hours of that and Holy Shit.
Like when,
when they start talking about,
uh,
the torture that the soldiers would engage in with people basically setting you
up on a bench and not letting you go to sleep.
Um,
you know,
kicking dudes in the balls over and over.
And uh,
Oh God,
like it gets really graphic and specific that book.
So,
and uh,
I think,
I don't know that I had ever read any Dostoevsky.
I haven't finished any dust he asked me,
but I started to read crime and punishment and
something else.
But I mean,
I don't know,
I think,
you know,
what,
what vox is biggest issue is that,
you know,
he's Devoxx.
He seems to be taking away
western men
from
wanting to
group up to be able to fight the migrant crisis.
That and that,
you know,
vox would say that,
he's not an intellectual.
Well,
who is the most interesting intellectual use subscribe to.
I Dunno,
I like Ralph Nader a lot.
I like his idea that the way that you're going to change things in the states is
through congress.
Um,
you know,
unless you have people that get out in the street basically,
if you can overtake Congress,
then you can,
um,
you can get work done,
good things done.
You know,
I didn't know that,
that
the Aaron,
what the clean air and Water Act,
Osha
and I think seat belts were laws that were drafted by Ralph Nader.
That's
pretty interesting.
I don't know Chris Hedges.
It's interesting to.
Yeah,
he's definitely a darker.
He's got to be way darker than most people.
I mean,
he was a war correspondent who's was captured by the Iraqi,
I think they were called the Republican Guard,
believe he thought he said he's going to be murdered,
but he ended up being turned over.
He's been in so many different war torn environments.
I mean,
Peterson can be dark and he's,
you know,
he,
he recommends reading a lot of dark literature,
but you know,
Chris hedges is a dark person.
You know what I mean?
You know,
you got people like,
uh,
Jocko willink and other people who are trained in the military,
but
you know,
hedges is a lot closer to what,
at least probably in the beginning of his career as being a bureau chief is a
lot closer to what a US citizen
isn't that close to how US citizen would react if I'm there to see war.
Can you recommend some dark literature?
Yeah,
go read,
go read the Gulag archipelago.
If you want to feel sick to your stomach,
maybe you won't be.
I probably felt sick to my stomach because I was listening for five hours one
day I was ripping stuff through a table saw
probably for three hours of that day building face frames for cabinets and it
just,
it just kept going on and on about the specifics of torture
in eastern Europe.
Yeah,
yeah.
Well
I'm kind of interested.
They have the audiobook for dog.
Is it unabridged?
Yeah.
Cause that's the thing is you got to read the unabridged version,
right?
You get to read every single word of
social needs in this work.
You know,
I've thought of the perfect screenplay,
uh,
ice,
I call it perfect,
but basically would open up with social since Harvard speech basically talking
to the individuals and then slowly it would like,
like transition to social needs and being in a cell
and it would basically the story,
the film would revolve around,
you know,
different people who had told him different stories.
I don't know that much about social needs in our,
how he collected a lot of those stories for that,
a piece of work.
But I think it would be a really interesting movie.
It could be really interesting film if created correctly,
probably better than
it could be on the,
it could be in the realm of
like a Schindler's list.
So if you can't use Liam Neeson line anymore because of his,
uh,
God,
Hollywood's obsession with him and taken to like everything has been reduced to
a,
uh,
to a meme.
And his is the taken meme,
right?
So you'd have to find somebody else to play social needs,
but it would be a good,
good story.
Good film.
Could be a Hollywood film too.
That was my thought.
I've done some videography work.
I do some videography work now for company out of Rochester,
New York,
CGI.
Basically I just shoot the raw content and send it off and they.
They edited down.
I do that in the carpentry.
What else?
Soon as they listened to jpl,
the symbols and he talks about no jumps at me when I watch movies.
Like what?
Oh yeah.
I know he does a lot about Harry potter.
Remember the Lion King?
Harry Potter.
Pinocchio.
The snake stands for evil.
I thought that this snake.
Awesome.
Yeah.
I don't know.
I don't know if that's the only thing that the snake symbolizes,
but that which man the predators are that which man has to pay attention to.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
Despite what everybody else has said,
despite what everybody else said,
I don't.
I think he was.
I think Peterson has been a net benefit.
Two people.
I don't know.
I don't know what that means.
No.
It might also be that you just didn't look for symbolism.
You know,
a director
director
will,
depending in which capacity the director is acting in,
but let's say somebody wrote a screenplay,
he'll go ahead and he'll take that screenplay and he'll pick out what he wants
to.
Uh,
he'll pick out exactly the symbolism that he wants to,
um,
highlight.
And if you read the reading,
but if you listen to the commentary of a movie,
you know,
you can listen to a director talking about,
oh,
I love this this way,
and I framed this shot this way,
you know,
and I let the flower,
I let the vas stay in the left part of the shot to symbolize the,
you know,
person passed the.
When you hear these things,
you think like,
how the hell would I ever get that?
Why would I think that the light in the back being left on
back there would mean something.
You know what I mean?
And it could just be that they watched,
they watched these shots,
they see these,
uh,
scenes afterward and they come up with it.
People love Peterson for his suggesting that,
Kevin,
I quit after winning.
Like I said,
I knew exactly what Peterson meant,
you know,
Peterson's message has been consistently that sometimes it's better to go for
peace than it is to go for a war and as soon as I read that,
it took me less than,
less than 10 seconds.
And I went,
oh,
that's the whole piece.
And then he said that he said it days later and I thought,
yeah,
that makes sense.
And I didn't really care.
I mean,
I don't care if Cavanaugh's is put in,
you know what I mean?
Like I'm not for.
I've not been a part of the state,
so I'm not for this state.
You know,
if I was in Kevin's shoes,
it'd be different.
Or if I was a person who
it would be different,
you know what I mean?
Uh,
That if I was part of like a bushes era,
if I was,
if I was one of the people involved in drafting the Patriot Act where Kevin,
I would go ahead and copyright it
into law.
See I the whole thing with Kevin or is everybody was watching the spectacle
and
you know,
to me it's like
this is not what you should be paying attention to.
Who is Kevin on?
What did he vote on?
I mean,
you're just not going to get a.
no,
I think you should listen to everybody.
No,
I think I like Owen Benjamin and I think he should be.
I think everybody can have something.
Everybody can have something worse.
Communicating.
Sure.
Everybody has the potential to communicate something to a.
I don't know.
Everybody has the potential to
something worth communicating.
Yeah.
Constrict.
Just criticism,
right?
Like I'm totally for the idea that if you hate somebody though,
why don't you hate them?
But I get it.
I guess there's probably reasons,
but if you don't like somebody you should listen.
Especially to those people
because they're going to be the ones who may have a grain of truth that they're
willing to share with you.
Whereas I like Owen Benjamin on Jordan Peterson.
I like box day,
but you know,
there's,
there's just everybody.
Every single one of those guys have said things that I go,
oh yeah,
no,
no.
And it's ridiculous.
Like,
like,
okay.
So the whole thing like it in,
I didn't watch it from the beginning,
but in own Benjamin's livestream with Fox day,
he comes up to the own.
Ben's was like,
yeah,
didn't he do something with a agenda 21?
And Vox is like,
no,
it was a basically as far as I can understand what it was,
he was invited to,
um,
to participate in the.
I don't know if it was the writing of any type.
I believe it was in the drafting of a,
I don't know what you would consider it,
but Peterson even has peter even talks about it as being something where,
you know,
he came into this and everybody's not predictions but there.
Uh
Huh.
Estimates,
no,
I don't know their projections,
everybody's projections where I very dark,
you know.
And as far as what he said,
he came out and he said that it,
it was different.
Now vox probably read that.
Uh,
I think it's,
I can't even remember what the article is called.
Something for a sustainable future.
Now I'd have to read it to be able to say exactly.
Owen went crazy and turned on the whole idw.
Well,
I don't know about that.
I don't really know anything.
What do you mean?
This whole lot?
This whole.
The whole idw thing.
Okay.
It's like,
look at it like this.
You're on a baseball team and you're making millions of dollars.
Okay.
And you,
you know,
you get together with your friends and you know,
it's like Rah Rah,
can you have this Kamar comradery and you know,
one of the guys comes up with a,
well,
you know,
well
this is what we are.
You know what I mean?
It's kind of a joke and
it permeates and people take it.
People being people on Youtube take it and the intellectual dark web and oh now
it's a joke that kinda now it's a running joke among people,
but it wasn't.
It's just these guys,
his thoughts,
you know what I mean?
These are just dudes,
albeit intelligent,
but they're just dudes.
Yeah.
They're just dudes.
Man.
Fucking rich dudes.
But they're just dudes.
Rogan called him out when?
Benjamin.
I don't know.
I don't remember that.
What do you mean?
What did he say?
John?
His name is.
Doth who the hell's doth?
Oh,
my name is Mike.
You just call me.
Mike
should have put that in the title.
Yeah,
Mike.
I'm surprised it's live for this long.
Robin called him out on his erratic.
You know,
I think,
I don't know because I haven't really followed Benjamin.
Nice to meet you too.
Haven't really fallen on Benjamin.
But you know,
I think one bedroom,
it was kind of in a tough place.
You know what I mean?
Didn't he get dropped by talent agency
or something?
I Dunno.
Do people are not in the best place right now?
He's a giant Viking maniac.
Ah,
uh,
yeah man,
I don't fault any of the people.
I mean somebody went on a killing spree.
They listen to Shapiro Shapiro got shit for it.
Peterson gets shit for stuff.
Rogan smokes bud and his friends with Alex Jones.
Alex Jones just goes on a tirade and Rogan gets shit for stuff.
And I mean,
uh,
what is his name?
Brian?
A Bret Weinstein has integrity and
things that he won't know.
Um,
let go,
you know,
so he ends up in a situation,
you know what I mean?
There's just,
if you drink coffee,
drink coffee,
these broadcasts will perk up your rhetoric.
No,
I haven't drank any coffee.
I have to work tomorrow and I'll probably get up around 4:30 so I can be at the
job site earlier.
I like to get there earlier,
so I'm not gonna drink anymore coffee tonight,
but
I don't know.
No clue.
I never really followed Milo.
It started in the garden job.
Hmm.
Yeah.
Youtube is put the correct on.
People in finished carpentry,
furniture making cabinet,
making cabinet.
Installing
specifically just cabinet installing.
Right now
it's still around.
There was one video where I thoughts on Patrion.
Well,
I listened to Pambula Moose back and like I was Kinda late finding Pamplemousse
you guys remember Pamplemousse before Jack Conte became the CEO of Patriot.
You guys remember who jack contact was before
he came up with Patriot and I remember I was watching Jack Conte at the same
time where he started posting videos about,
I've got this great idea with a,
I don't know if it was his girlfriend at the time,
Natalie,
the girl he plays music with.
Well they,
they,
uh,
arrange these songs.
Um,
and it's,
they're great.
I mean,
he is definitely a very creative musician and they put out quality.
Have you checked?
No,
I haven't.
They put out quality music.
He puts out quality music content and Natalie,
I think her name is.
And at the same,
at around 2013,
there was like 14.
He was saying that,
oh,
we're coming out with this big thing,
you know,
it's going to be this way that you can help creators and,
because I think they were,
they were looking for a way to be able to make money.
And then of course,
you know,
you come up with your own idea and,
and,
uh,
then you know,
that then you figure out that that idea can benefit others.
So you friends,
the enum friend in PSS,
I've talked with Adam a few times,
I don't know,
PSA,
stitch stitch.
Is it such,
um,
you know,
so he was a good musician and
I know what's going on with
Patriot.
Why should I care though?
I mean,
well I know why I should care.
But
yeah,
you can talk politics.
You can type about politics and I talk about it.
I didn't start clipping the content for the money when I started making quite a
bit of money.
Yes,
I did it yet.
Well yeah,
I did it for the money for a long time.
Well,
well I save for a long time for about six months.
I mean I didn't,
I mean I still clipping clips but you know,
when I realized that,
uh,
that I could make money at it.
Yeah.
I don't make any money on this channel now youtube is demonetized this channel.
I have a possibility of getting re monetized.
But
um,
there's no guarantee that a youtube is going to allow me to enter the Youtube
partnership program again.
Yeah,
I dunno,
I don't really have that much.
The oppression will end one day.
I don't think that's true.
I don't think depression will ever end.
It will just be different forms of oppression.
You can't get rid of oppression
and if you get.
If you were to be able to get rid of oppression,
you wouldn't even recognize the paradigm that humans would live in because
humans wouldn't even resemble there.
Today.
The prophecy speaks of a new website that will from the ashes of Youtube.
Yeah.
I don't know.
Google is like in bed with the state.
So
you think you that
you think that youtube is going to be replaced.
Really?
You don't see that happening.
It's in bed with Google is in bed with the state.
If it keeps this up.
I don't think so.
They hold all the cards
now.
Now if they piss the state offer,
they piss politicians off.
I even know what that means.
If they piss people off the people that matter,
then you might have some antitrust issues
if we have weaponized autism on our side.
Yeah,
I mean that's kind of what I'm doing right now.
It's kind of an autistic thing.
Sit in front of a camera.
Well,
the,
you know,
we're working towards a positive.
We are far beyond the antitrust.
I don't like the idea that Obama was a liberal,
cause he wasn't,
you know,
Obama was as right wing as Bush.
Clinton was,
as right wing as Bush,
you know,
you haven't had,
you haven't had liberal since Nixon and the only reason Nixon gave him the
liberal policies because he was afraid.
No,
that's the truth.
And I can tell you exactly why obamacare was Romney care and Romney care,
I believe was,
I mean,
it's.
Obama is a globalist Marxist.
See that?
You have to think about it differently.
That's not exactly true.
Okay.
I mean,
there,
there is some truth to that.
But
Obama I believe really liked control and he liked being able to control
geopolitics and the TPP.
I believe
the TPP was meant to help cripple China.
Um,
and we didn't go through with it.
Of course it's bad for America,
but it was supposed to be,
as far as I've read,
it's supposed to be very bad for China.
Control doesn't care about your idealisms.
So you know,
a Bama liked,
you know,
he's a,
he's a bad dude.
Obama sought to deconstruct,
you know what?
I don't think Obama gave me shit.
Okay.
Obama was doing what was going to make him money just like Clinton.
Alright.
You think those guys care,
you think they have?
I think they have some ideology.
Hell No.
You have to to get to where you are.
Then you have to kiss ass here and kiss ass there and you know and huddle up
here and huddle up there and you know,
you have to play the game.
You play the game and then once you're the lead chief
then it's just about now I can do favors for people that secure me in
the future because I've only got four to eight years here.
But once I'm out I don't want to ever have to work again.
I don't want to have to do anything.
Not that they would if they didn't cozy up to.
You have to be a lizard.
Obama's ideology is Satan and it's divas part.
He sold out the US like the last four presidents.
It goes back more than four.
I mean,
I,
I certainly think that Reagan cutting the taxes on the wealthy was a terrible
idea.
No,
the idea that the super rich or anything like
you and I are,
are not true.
I mean,
first off,
a lot of very wealthy people get to where they're at by working extremely hard.
Okay.
So they're very driven and that already disqualifies them from being like most
people.
No.
Reagan had a lot of things that weren't
very good.
No wealthy people aren't bad.
Yeah.
Can you.
The bleed is going on for two hours.
Is it true that people who tend to be assholes become either criminals or
politicians?
I don't know about that,
but if the person's an asshole and they just stay in ass
and what may be an asshole to somebody else may not be to other people.
Like if you're a disc,
a disagreeable person,
you know,
maybe people see that as
having asshole tendencies.
What is wealth?
Wealth is money assets
that span over generations.
I mean if you have enough wealth and it's the first generation of it,
then that's.
You can still at wealth and being the first generation.
Do you have thoughts on psychedelics?
Oh,
like what Jonathan?
Well,
I think cannabis can make cancer cells destroy themselves in mice.
I think high,
high doses of A.
I think there's a medical article of a single girl being,
um,
that when there were low doses of thc and cannabinoids,
there was no effect and actually exacerbates,
exacerbated the cancer cells,
but when she started taking extremely high doses that her cancer cells,
uh,
pretty much wiped out.
But,
um,
I don't know how much further research has been done.
Hmm.
Well,
I don't,
I don't think so.
That's true.
Chris.
I think that's a good general.
I think that's.
Well the did the generalization.
I think it's true,
but it's not true in all cases.
What do you think about the moon landing
being a hoax?
It's hard for me to imagine it being a hope.
I mean,
there were a certain,
uh,
there were quite a few
apollo missions that we're gearing up to be able to go to the moon before they
actually went to the moon.
So,
you know,
if people think about the moon landing is being a hoax or that single moon
mission,
there were other
missions that were,
uh,
that were vital to be able to get to the moon.
I believe,
if I'm remembering correctly,
Sophia,
all I'd say is like,
how do we know that we can't get through the van Allen Belt?
How do you know that
time and pressure
and did do fruit and
what is a podcast about?
I don't know.
Ask Me your question.
I have sophia probably 10 years ago.
Yeah.
No,
I haven't had a girlfriend before.
Two Thousand 16
and 2016.
I don't really watch
Netflix all that much.
I watched mine hunter.
I watched that last show with the uh,
which is kinda old since 2017 with the Canadian organized mom.
I think it was called blood something.
I'm from Chicago
in my thirties,
who
I watched a lot of youtube.
I've been trying to pay them more and more attention to climate change.
Anthropogenic climate change.
What do you watch on Youtube?
A watch Russia America.
So like a watch
Chris Hedges show recently listened to the Ralph Nader Radio Hour.
Uh,
a lot of different stuff.
So you,
Joe
just graduated boot camp near Chicago?
Well,
yeah.
What branch of the service?
I don't know what they call career paths in the navy.
But what's your,
uh,
what's the field that you're in?
No,
it's not Chris.
I'm not there right now.
I've moved.
It depends on where you're in Chicago,
but no,
it's not that bad
if you're,
if you're unfortunately unfortunate enough to be in a certain situation in a
certain tire in place,
then yeah,
then it can be bad.
My father was a union carpenter in Chicago and he worked on the west side and he
had been in multiple shootouts,
basically gang rival gangs shooting at each other
instead.
It was the most ridiculous stuff they ever saw.
Of course they'd go for cover,
but
basically a vehicle would roll up
and would just start shooting at a house.
No,
not really aiming.
You're in tech school.
You a feminist?
Sounds like a loaded question.
Do you think Americans are stupid or more stupid?
You mean
it's like a.
You asking that question is a.
What do you mean by more stupid?
As far as what?
Ooh,
I think Americans more isolated than other people in other countries.
I think America is lucky because it's southern border of Mexico,
whereas Europe,
southern border is Africa.
America would look like Europe if you flipped Mexico and Africa or it wouldn't.
You'd have a pretty authoritarian
element in the south
everywhere as people from all over the world.
Maybe less so and
some countries.
Oh,
America.
Certainly as more people who probably migrated here from other countries,
but.
Hmm.
Well this is getting.
It's been two hours and 15 minutes now.
Yeah.
Well it's always fun to run on some people.
Alright guys.
I'm gonna.
Get going
some dinner and do whatever I do.
You're welcome.
Hopefully I can figure something out at some other point and maybe get monetized
and
we'll see if I can eventually ever
make it back on here permanently again
later.
Guys.